okay so this is our real thoughts with
the release of a particular game this
week on Pokemon the first movie I'm so
excited to talk about this because
everyone thinks I really hate Pokemon
and I don't really I don't really hate
it it's not like say you know there's
things I legitimately hate it just
suddenly turned into like a thing online
and then all the face got so insulted I
make fun of Pokemon I like oh I'm gonna
belong with me honestly we're gonna do
something else before this but then you
said someone's asking us to do Pokemon
the first movie I'm like oh yes let's do
it
I got a few requests like I like your
way yeah cuz we're game coming out what
are your thoughts and people like what
do you think of the new Pokemon game I'm
like look what what the hell would I
have to say I'm not playing what even
people that love this stuff what the
hell can you say about this thing it's
like tickets I say find a picture of a
leaf you go out of trees there's a leaf
there's a leaf there's but when I heard
it somebody described like cuz I said
what is Pokemon Goa this thing is
everywhere oh you just go around on your
phone and find these random little
stickers and you take a picture of and
you collect them like that can't be it
there has to be more as I know never
what my reply was a cuz it was a Glee
was Tamara telling you man we were all
at a convention recently and we were
staying in one suite and everyone was
talking about this game and uh and she
or Malcolm I think they both were
describing it you just looked at them
with this blank stare just that's it
this is like spoken like a true asshole
who never liked bogey and and I don't
like Pokemon but I never hated it and
from a marketing standpoint
yes yeah watching you genius most
ingenious ideas I get the game like I
get the idea behind it and I'm like I
like a scavenger hunt yeah like that's
that's fine I mean I get it um I
couldn't play it but but okay even for
like this sounds like something like
Disney would throw out like in its spare
time like you know ooh find Cinderella's
mice or something like that
oh there and just put it in random
places but this is like a phenomenon
it's like huge and this is
literally what Nintendo has been doing
for 20 just Pokemon yeah and Mario yeah
I don't why you're surprised I was like
so big Disney which throughout its spare
time no well would you intend those
entire master no nobody would care it
didn't it'd be like a little game for
kids that might get a few bucks of
profit for them or something like that
but this is just like all these phone
companies now are like you know hey you
want play pokemon go better come here
come here I mean they're trying to use
it because they know it's such a big
deal well its inner its interactive and
it's idiot-proof somebody was like is
something different like that it's
interactive it's pre branded and it's
idiot-proof somebody was posing me just
like that apparently there's some other
game that was in development for six
years that has five times the number of
features and the meme so something like
yes but it wasn't called Pokemon and
therefore more people are blend I'm like
yes pretty much pleased open course
that's how it works like it already came
pre branded everybody knows what pokémon
is and somebody's like that game is and
fun times the features I'm like that's
why kids won't be playing it like like
this idiot-proof
that's like when Paranormal Activity
came out and people are like there has
never been a movie where you don't see
the ghost it's like fuck you it's been
done millions of times it's so much
better but this one just got really good
there's a reason this works is because
and this has been Nintendo strategy
along in rubber hate Nintendo or their
strategy for my money I was kind of done
with it after I became an adult um but
it's always geared towards families we
get to feeling a little cute good do
critters you think a picture with your
phone and then you're tripping in a bull
let make them fight it's like
cockfighting a little card took you for
family so it's same thing honestly with
uh with the game with everything Pokemon
I really don't care I really say that
more because the reactor from you guys
are amazing
you're just taking so personally and I
love it the more Percy on please never
stop it's a reality it brings me much
Joan the reality of it is Arg our little
cousins played Pokemon there yeah late
so we knew I need like and I
that was fun to hear them talk about it
it was actually really cute like they
were so into it so yeah the only the
only thing that bothered me like
legitimately bothered me about Pokemon
it still does is is use of the ingenious
marketing behind it where it literally
the entire concept is gotta catch them
all I remember back in the late 90s when
I heard that it was like wow they're not
even trying to hide it they're literally
just saying the film was called the
first movie that that is the only thing
about Pokemon that legitimately bothers
me words just it's so it's like they
couldn't even bother with the cynicism
but I couldn't even put up the pretense
it's just like but Pokemon by us yeah
that's kind of the only thing that
legitimately bothered me about it but
and it's still to a certain degree does
like years later I still have never
really gotten over that just got it
can't you know you gotta you gotta um
and then send the fucking themes under
the collar catch em all the week we're
up Widow market and we grew up to the
Ninja Turtle okay in which they have
their designer marketing yeah I don't
know I'm messing around that the 80s and
the early 90s didn't cynically market
towards kids yeah a transformer I'm just
saying they put up the pretense of you
know they tried to at least pretend
there was more than that and with
Pokemon they just fucking gave up
they're like why are we even pretending
you know what just say you gotta get
them all or else I you know just say
you're a loser
yeah um so uh so this movie comes out
and Ozzy the only reason I reviewed is
cuz everyone wanted me to review it and
I straight-up admit I know almost
nothing about Pokemon so those would be
the last room to review it and who hated
this review be careful what you fuckin
this for no actually the funny thing is
like when I first day cuz I was like I
think the first review we did when we
got back oh the glasses combos our first
one off of you two so it was a huge hit
actually people loved it but that's
before the numbers got even as big as
they are now the actual the actual
verbal written reaction though was very
uh it was all over the map and like that
were my favorites there was a handful of
people were just like I wanted him to
view them disappointed that he didn't
take the time to watch the theories
beginning to end like a bitch dead oh
yeah he's good I think it's still going
Islam I say it might be I've got
everything in Japan is still going it
never stops
um but yeah so this movie could be real
it could be one piece well what I hear
about it is that you know it's for the
most part the dub is pretty close to the
original until they get to the end where
they throw in this half-assed bullshit
message about not fighting which shit
celeriac what's window you know which a
the Japanese would never do I mean they
know that cake a let's not bring up the
war no no okay that's how you know that
they need to keep fighters a long time
ago God for a face they would never be
that stupid but then be I guess you know
Americans are like are the people
dumping over just like well we look we
had a lot of bad stuff with Power
Rangers and Ninja Turtles and everybody
complaining about violence so let's put
in this anti fighting message at the end
that makes no sense and clearly didn't
work those 12 billion pokemons going out
and doing this and I'm a little curious
what yellow cartoon rat fighting and
like this is what we need to fuckin
worry about this country's so fuckin
stupid sometimes
it blows on Power Rangers it's a bunch
of freaking teenagers in skittle colored
pajamas don't bite my metal wing
costumes boy ones none of my favorite my
fo a favor if you watch the Animaniacs
parody of Power Rangers they do this
brilliant satire because they do the
little message at the end what do we
learn thing and he's like kids
violence is not cool so the next time
you want to jump inside a giant robot
and height a giant bug just say uh-uh
and it was just so such a clever punch
in the face to those idiots I like it if
I sit that's what's warming our kids me
is we lived through the 80s when ninja
Inge became the big
in thing and when ninjas have robots and
when parents everywhere were worried
that all of us were going to stab each
other with real katana swords you know
and yeah it was ninjas and robots and we
survived that just fine except in
Britain where I found it from a friend
that apparently ninja Inge was outlawed
or subtly been an influx of ninjas as
laughing he returned probably during
World War two and like after yes it's a
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles and I'm
like this is why brexit happens so this
bullshit ending is thrown in but the
rest is apparently with one or two you
know lines that obviously would not be
in Japan you know oh they're still
Vikings are out there mostly Minnesota
uh ah um that's awesome I know what
Minnesota Vikings ochio
oh uh so this that this movie plays it
clearly is just a part 29 x of their
story uh you know cuz we have no idea
what you two is or view we just know
it's a big deal in this universe and we
just when we watch this film it's all I
got out is mu is a big f and deal but
just yeah I just
I actually got more of it out of uh out
of the Smash Brothers game I was at you
like hello youtube I think she the funny
thing is I knew the what base knowledge
I needed to know about Pokemon I picked
up from the smash from them before we
ever saw the fucking movie like oh this
beauty okay it's like I know their
character so yeah and when I saw cuz I
remember being advertised so I was kind
of like okay maybe this will kind of
help explain what these things are where
they come from it's nothing it just
dropped you right in the middle and it's
just like go and that's clearly the kind
of movie it is it's made for the kids
that grew up with the show and if you
like the show you'll probably like the
movie fine though I hear even fans we're
kind of talking about that ending like I
I just don't get that I mean it's like I
know the message but how does any of
this make inviting these characters all
my life my life is love yeah Mike
Wednesday
it's kind of like saying if you were
like playing with ghostbusters as a kid
suddenly being like you know what
they're there don't capture the go no
they're dead you can let them rest in
peace a little figure out their way it's
like it's all ghostbusters good I think
I think we should release all the ghosts
just get them in a program a rehab
center my kids a seal why can't we just
talk and he'll you know it's like
suddenly realizing all this stuff you've
been doing is bullshit but that'd be
like ah you know what next episode they
go back to busting ghosts again it's
like it makes no sense why our country
is stupid this is how we end up with
Trump this is done dumb but the funny
guy is we still have to let me have some
violence we have to give this movie a
little bit of credit that it at least
didn't do the Digimon movie thing where
they just took parts from other Digimon
movies like from three different movies
and just threw it together as just like
movie and like not a bit connects like
we don't like him enough well this
doesn't make sure that did explain a
thing
Robo sip Robo tech that did that back in
the day yes so we have to say well done
pokey
I think you're at least having a
somewhat coherent story you have to
watch this bajillion other shows to get
it but at least there's a beginning
middle or no case of the the original
odd noskov valley the win which they
changed to something like the Woodend
warriors and released in the early 80s
and Miyazaki never went to release a
fucking film here since then because
event took John Lasseter like I don't
know getting him drunk on a picture with
him and an octopus or something like
I'll release more like it so yeah just
just release the damn thing I mean
unless unless like Pokemon was really
like chock-full of hentai or something I
don't really know what the big deal
would be do you remember ear and I'm
sure there's a Pokemon hentai that
exists and I'm sure Brad Jones is
founded so from the show and the movie I
again having seen very little valley at
you sat down watch it is there anything
that you actually remember like well
that's kind of neat oh that's kind of
fun or that I mean like no the only
thing I can remember the bad guys I like
the idea behind the bad guys
they almost never made me laugh but sort
of their voices were a little funny I
like the little bit more sounds like
this all like the gong who sounds like
this and I like their little cat guys
like if I was a kid I would like that I
would like those three um everything
else just seems like very bland generic
not that I don't like literally do not
remember a goddamn this is a hyper man I
remember the intro was very exposition
heavy to the point that I'm just like
why did they even bother they could have
just did cuz any kid who's gonna see
this movie probably would have been
watching the show you could have just
dumped him into it cuz the parents don't
give a shit I didn't give a shit yeah
like I was like you know just tell your
damn story I don't need that it's like
within elicit something evident in there
but him like shut up just get on with it
um I remember I remember there was like
Pikachu took a good beating and that was
on himself
yeah that was very cathartic for me um
the tears as a Pokemon bringing back the
boy that was pretty funny I just talked
about half as like a fairy tale just
shit something out and then the fumes
went into some guys knows that he got
this idea uh his tears after he sent
this thing to its near death how many
times it seems like no don't is there
way around yeah yeah no you're right
like Pikachu should be like you know I'm
glad he's fucking dead you know he keeps
me in a ball and then like you see he
has me fighting myself and stop I and
I'm allowed to talk it's gonna be just
me I'm glad he's stone I'm heavy stone
somebody drank the kool-aid or Stockholm
Syndrome I think this is very abusive
relationship when you get down to it but
you know it seems to work for them they
put the fun back in dysfunction and
there's something about again just from
me and I think this is because I grew up
with like those marketing show it's like
I like whenever a pokémon's released and
it says its name a again it's ingenious
hammering in the name but Tom you know
and I realized I was a sucker for that
because when the Transformers movie came
out the Michael Bay one when Megatron
comes out what's the first thing he says
ah a Megatron now that makes no sense
why would he say that but I kind of got
a chill cuz I'm like oh that's just like
the cartoon like
said that sometimes and it's like
there's something stupid the negative
that I am Shila boy yeah there's
something then your hearts there's
something so dumb and manipulative about
that that I can't get this childhood
like you know just eating it's pure junk
food but sometimes junk foods again
sometimes candies okay and it really is
okay - I think I you find EE I don't you
I don't judge it um you know I mean I
joke my friends and I have a saying we
do an anime night weekly and friends
don't let friends watch DBZ but you know
the thing is there's plenty of people
who like DBZ and love it and I I don't
judge it it's just that my thing in
Pokemon was that my thing I was too old
with my college when it started I loved
the voice cast a DBZ and that's not
because I'm friends with most of them
that has a complete load especially
because I'm friends with no no I felt
like the voice cast you know I'm just
the the show that type of show doesn't
really grab me yeah hokey mom as a type
of anime that I even watched as a kid
probably wouldn't have grabbed me I
don't think even if I was the writing I
will grab me I might've it might have
grabbed me a small window but no any
might have ran me just so I could
survive school cuz I got a feeling I
would have had to have known what the
hell is well I like to think would
create things with creative creatures
and there's nothing but these weird
strange-looking creatures that you're
supposed to catch them I would have to
love this as a kid I guess it the you
know I'd end up fighting install extinct
distinct fucking impression I would have
been busy trying to just create my own
new Pokemon like why don't you can I
mean that's gotta actually bothering
with it if not I think we have a sequel
to Pokemon government we can make cuz
that's gotta be a thing creating your
own pokemon that'd be insane if they
didn't think of it yet I will say this
though booking a con right after the
release of that game Oh everybody was
coming with you play pokemon girl did
you fuckin see your fuckin ago Oh Mike
hold still there's a Pikachu in your
goatee
okay oh look there's a bob lazar jarvis
a fancy sandwich you guys were here get
your girl
yeah there's apparently quite a few
squirrels or some shit on us with maybe
more looking at us it why the bull
bizarre is in my bed so um yeah if this
movie clearly were not a fan of but it's
it is one of those times we just had to
acknowledge quite clearly it's not made
for us uh you know this is junk food
it's pure junk food it's you know badly
made candy for kids but we grew up with
junk food we grew up with badly made
candy and we totally get it
we make fun of it because we're adults
and it's so easy to make fun of and the
reaction from you guys is beautiful
they're beautiful reactions never stop
with them uh but in terms of our real
thoughts I that's what's called real
thoughts we really don't give a shit if
you like it alright you know and I'll be
on it's like one thing that did kind of
bug me a bit about the film is just you
look at that versus something like
strangely enough like the chipmunk
adventure I was like I honestly thought
the animation pokemons even my anime
standards was kind of weak yeah it's um
ya know it's pretty I'm like if you're
gonna do a movie like I would have
wanted something more and I know and you
know there's somebody tried to tell me
it's like well you know anime has a
lower frame rate you know and they're
they're more I've seen so fills na mono
and they're more focused on uh none
stills and it's not as heavy in the
fluid and I'm like well first they're
talking to me like I had never seen a
nanny
yeah first of all he has a midnight I
was I was just staring at this guy like
and I'm just like listen I have seen a
fuck ton of anime films I've seen a fuck
ton of anime you know television shows
you know well into like good what 250
now maybe by my count
um I I'm sorry it's not that great
animation I've seen worse but it it
didn't look you know and I don't know
she i animes I have very simple styles
but are still very artistic I and there
was nothing that really grabbed me about
that so even on a visual level I was
like really like I I know it's weird to
say this but I expected more from poker
like I was hoping like I'm like okay you
get these freaking critters fighting I'm
not it's like really cool and I just
kind of felt like mm I thought happened
my thong all honesty is because we saw
something similar with Ninja Turtles you
know that show was and the toys and
everything were just huge gigantic I
want sure was cool no no yeah you
couldn't get enough at the supply and
demand was so insane that they're just
like push them out as fast as you can't
we're just we're not getting enough and
I'm sure with pokemons the same thing
like with the movie I was just demanding
of movies I can get it out as fast as
you can so I get it but we a city like
this is your animation too though it's
not yeah but you look at the recent
teenage me Ninja Turtles movies when
they did the reboots though like I was
like okay no there's no the movies are
different yeah this is pretty like no I
think for Phil for some reason America
when we do films we really want them to
be like we really do want to step them
up and I'm sure like Pokemon the first
movie like had a little bit better
animation you know compared to the show
but it's still essentially kind of visit
there's nothing Wow
in it you know is later we watch the
chipmunk adventure again we're just like
voice this animation so phenomenal we
have no idea but it's incredible it's
incredible animation and the transform
transformers the movie you know the
anime one phenomenal animation uh you
know so it's one those things like in
with the Ninja Turtle same thing like
when we do a film we really want to
throw a lot of money at it
and I think there is something to at
least what I've seen with like the
Pokemon movie and actually the digit
those three Digimon movies you know I
think if they just let them play on
their own you know actually the
animation would have been decent
probably would have been okay um you
know especially by the time it came out
but yeah I think when that Pokemon movie
it's just a get it out fast as you can
we just we can't contain this we just
can't well that's okay that's what
bothers me like legitimately but when we
talk about real thoughts that's what
legitimately bothers me about the film
is the cheapness of it like I what do
you what I mean what the fuck do we say
about the plot okay we made fun of the
fact that they the American version has
them
making up or whatever at the end but
really what comes out of the plot it's
like I can't sit like the fucking shit
movies but diamond smuggling my so
Stefan you know half the things we saw
as kids make no sense I'm not gonna sit
here in rip apart the pot and foot so
illogical Pokemon fans can now if you
hate the movie on its own levels of
Pokemon game you've earned that speak up
I couldn't tell you this is a good
product
yeah okay by Pokemon standards yeah you
know so I can't make four there but I
can say I'm just like when I look at
something and it feels cheap
I do feel that's a bit of a ripoff cuz
I'm just like this is such a heat this
was such a huge phenomenon that I'm like
well at least you should get like
something out of it like if I were an
adult I'd be like well like I am an
animation fan I see animated films as an
adult and if I somehow got stuck taking
like you know my niece or nephew to like
norm of the north or something yeah okay
I'm a little bit that's not I'd be kind
of pissed of like you know I wasn't
expecting that what the hell's going on
here but I don't be a little
better-looking right miss like so yeah
that's that's my gripe with the yeah so
I mean we we clearly don't like it it's
not made for us um and and we understand
the need for junk food you know spoonful
of sugar all that nonsense out Pokemon
go classic Gaelic classic game that well
I will say this I was gonna say may
change the course of you know our lives
but for some it might it's already kind
of getting people in accidents and shit
it's finding dead bodies
well shit actually I would say I will
say this it isn't it is a double-edged
sword but the one thing I I do like
about like I'm people want to play it go
nuts like I'm not judging anybody who
plays it like what I actually what I
really like about it is that kids who
normally would be inside or going
playing a fucking video game are
actually going outside I like that in
the Sun the day globe which burns the
skin but gives you precious vitamin ie I
have no idea how much like you know an
energy it takes just to point your phone
like this but you're right
they are going outside we have to travel
they start to see the world through
their phone and that's stupid but
they're still seeing the world somehow
they're going outside the thing
it's a trick to get you to actually look
at the world only you're doing it
through your baby the creator of Pokemon
is like what if I done just they're all
staying inside you're playing this
stupid game and watching our stupid
shows and they forgotten what the day
ball looks like so maybe I can create
something they can have them go outside
but they're still on a screen
technically but we're tricking them into
going outside yep
I may be maybe this is like a strange
way kind of the most brilliant thing
ever made it's like Harry Potter
tricking kids into reading mazes
tricking kids to going outside that part
of it I like cuz I do think we become
kind of a vegetable nation oh yeah that
ironically doesn't eat vegetables so I'm
all for that like there's some
librarians are saying like I don't know
how the game works but I guess they're
like setting some pokemons up in the
library and then they're just like
latter
hey when kids come in like with the
Pokemon thing like they're literally
some libraries of like putting together
like dossiers on the game so that you
can talk to kids about it and get them
to stay in the library
well oh that's kind of smart it's
something kind of creepy
hey kids I've got books I searched I
know I know jelly tricky with education
you know what good for them good but of
course it is the dachshund hey kids
I've got Pokemon get your fat ass back
you probably saw a bitch call me so but
no that's a good example I like that
people are you know life and on the dark
side there's now already stories but
yeah like some idiot walks into the
middle of the street gets hit by bus
you're an adult you know what I don't
I'm not gonna lie I call that natural
selection oh no that is something where
it's like you know giving a generation
the idiots would get weeded out somehow
like even in medieval times there was
some moron who walked in front of the
horse you know because he was you know
playing I don't know stone the witch or
something like on his hands down anyway
but but and then like some some people
been reporting that it's getting a
little too hyper competitive like like I
get pry among the adults but oh I have
no doubt like when I see that I'm like
watch that is some 20 like 20 year old
asshole fanboy it's always okay so I
can't have nice things it's like geeks
it's so funny we spend decades trying to
get out from under the oppression of
like jocks and shit and now we're our
own worst fucking enemy yeah I can beat
each other up over fucking Pokemon
yeah it's a vicious circle really makes
you I was gonna say it's the first day
well our line I always like is that the
internet the only place where geeks and
losers can't be bullies is some truth to
that it's like um
but yeah so that's you get it with the
movie I mean it's not our movie it's not
for us if it's your thing I really mean
that we don't agree I don't think it's
the worst I didn't think it'd cost
violence among anybody oh god you know
if anything against Kali Ghostbusters
where it's like you're kind of chasing
things and stuff if anything is almost
decreasing even back in the day at a
tight when I just hated Pokemon because
it had oversaturated everything and was
everywhere my health things don't change
um even then when parents were coming up
with that argument like does encourage
violence i sat there is like a 20 year
old and was just like are you fucking
kidding me
let's like shut the hell up yeah who
ever pretends they're the polky ma they
pretend they're the kid with the ball
throwing the Pokemon look at that look
at that again that's why a lot of adults
like a lot of parenthood ghostbusters
cuz you're pertaining the chase goes
you're not going against each are you
now awaiting each other okay and let's
let's get something straight here in the
few minutes that we have left okay have
you ever seen puppies playing or cats or
dogs or whatever roughhousing is just a
natural part of life
what's cuz I have played violent video
games yeah it's because they watched a
Pokemon obviously like that is just part
of fun is wrestling and then playing and
pretending you're a Ghostbuster Pokemon
or a ninja turtle and and just you know
flinging around some cheap plastic sword
or whatever and just that's just gonna
happen people were doing it with sticks
in the Middle Ages I'm sure they blame
you know back then you can blame the
violent Bible oh it's all biblical blame
the Bible for that one
yeah so just fuck that noise who's angry
today
Pokemon break that at us uh so yeah
that's our thoughts um like I said not
both a ton and not a ton that we have to
say about it but yeah you got the game
enjoy it please be safe to be safe with
it but go outside please enjoy the Sun
um that's about it and we'll just see
you next one but you need me I need you
that's how it goes right boo here mom